for more now on how the White House
plans to address the crisis what it
could mean for a Biden reelection
campaign Rich Edson he's got that story
live in Washington for us hey Rich good
morning
good morning Bill the administration is
considering drastic measures including
barring more migrants at the border and
increasing prosecutions for those
Crossing illegally that's according to
axios moderate Democrats say the White
House needs more of that especially as
President Biden considers running for
re-election they're warning the White
House that Republicans will campaign
relentlessly on record encounters at the
southern border during his term and
they're telling him to change course
they the Republicans whoever runs
against the president is going to use
open borders uh etc etc uh the way they
used it against some Democrats so uh you
know I think she still has time uh to
start really addressing the Border in a
compassionate way but at the end of the
day you got to enforce the law
cueller says the White House has the
tools to address the Border in a
compassionate way though he says he's
not sure if they will Fox News poll
conducted about a month from the midterm
elections found Republicans had more
than a 20-point advantage on addressing
border security political analysts say
the President also has to look Beyond
just holding the White House in 2024
urge they have the control of the Senate
and they have control of the White House
this is a necessity not just because of
the substance of the issue but because
Republicans are well positioned to take
the Senate if the Democrats don't
moderate on a whole host of issues
in two years Americans will vote to fill
33 seats in the U.S Senate Democrats
currently control 23 of them a much more
difficult landscape for them heading
into this next cycle all right Rich more
to come Rich Hudson thanks Washington
D.C